[Musique]
joyeux noël jude as-tu été sage
cette année
jude oui j'ai ça veut dire
juif tu vas avoir plein de bons
cadeaux pour noël
c'est différent tu les vois en ligne et
ils sont très très très heureux tu peux
voir qu'ils
sont fous de joie  que hé
je n'ai pas perdu le père noël le père noël est toujours là
ils aiment ça
et le père noël l'aime aussi
notre village au pôle nord a plus de
cent mille elfes qui vivent ici
et en ce moment ils sont dans différents
ateliers qui fabriquent des jouets
[musique]
nous '  J'ai créé l'application santa hq, il y a
en fait des
enfants qui passent beaucoup de temps euh à regarder des
ipads et à parler à leurs amis
via leurs smartphones, etc.